so our basketball season officially
kicked off last night they tell me I'm
not really a sports sports fella that
what they say not one of those sports
fellas you see but my writers informed
me about a thing that's called the NBA
listen to this it's like the WNBA but
it's for men and apparently a lot of
people love it and it's exciting and I
got to sit down with the Houston Rockets
star player James Harden a tremendous
guy I was so excited to meet him an
exceptional athlete and a really cool
dude let's watch it together as a
segment for this TV show holy cow I'm
here with gold medal winner all-star and
player for the the Houston Rockets James
Harden look here's a beer you drafted in
19 years old when I was 19 I was dry
humping my mattress you were getting cut
how did how did that work out worked out
pretty good I was immersed in the
drought and I mailed it I delivered and
I was consistent throughout the season
consistency is the most important thing
if I started I finished promoted isn't
an intimidation factor like people are
afraid of it on the court yeah I don't
think so what's the sitch downstairs all
natural all measure could you float a
bottle cap in it wasn't planning on
asking you that one you seem cool I trim
it up a little bit you can't have any
Sleepy Hollow branches down there yeah
so I watch some clips of you here uh you
are amazing you make basketball look
easy is it yeah you must be popular with
the ladies are you are you big ladies
man yeah yeah you got to be a pickup
lines that work uh no not one in
particular just when I cook whatever
comes to you know my mine yeah keep it
in
right remember never push into the
female the female what about you
yeah work for me I do hi I'm James
Harden if that doesn't work
hi I'm the NBA's James Harden if that
doesn't work
look at this highlight reel on my
youtube phone app of NBA's James Harden
isn't that dude sweet now look up behold
it's I party that's not gonna work what
would you be if you weren't a basketball
player profit oh we're a singer you did
that footlocker add were you saying
badly are you a bad singer do you like
saying what was it would you just you
did the footlocker ad where you sang oh
yeah others have badly do you ever just
to put yourself like in a good mood do a
360 slam dunk uh I can't do it this
issue's member jo-jo you ever miss an
alley and go alley whoops
y'all just totally person to repair the
bad pass if you promise me next time
you'll instead go alley whoops here
let's pretend I have the ball oh and we
missed Le whoops no big deal James do
you talk trash we're just walking around
or yeah just walk around nice pants fat
pants what's one of your favorite lines
like if I was gonna talk trash what how
would I talk trash sorry any sensor
uncensored we can swear balls hey Klaus
do this score on me your dicks made of
margarine [ __ ] stop trying to this game
with your margarine dick [ __ ] there's
nobody's gonna see this it's not a
midnight James I'm blown away man you a
cool cat for sure I really appreciate
you taking the time thanks so much
gold medalist all-star star player for
the Houston Rockets James Harden
everybody
you